every year for the past few years Riot
has been putting out a brand new shiny
cinematic at the start of each League
season to get everyone hyped for the new
year and every year people get hyped
this year though they put out a
cinematics so abysmally poor that people
are genuinely beginning to question if
Riot has just given up on League
[Music]
is the New Year treating you first of
all if you've only just left the haze of
the holidays then might I direct you
towards our new merch we've got all
kinds of goodies and hoodies for you to
check out over there you already know
the touchgrass one is my absolute
favorite you can find the link to
everything in the description box below
in this life we all look forward to
something that happens once a year could
be a birthday could be a holiday for a
lot of League fans like myself we look
forward to The League season cinematic
for five years now Riot has released a
six cinematic to get fans hyped for the
upcoming season we've seen the
animations improve over the years the
lore has got deeper the fight scenes
more intense the narration more
enthralling and for a lot of people like
myself it kind of peaked this time last
year when they released the call I mean
just just look at this
[Music]
you get the idea it reminds us that
league is a game steeped in law that our
favorite Champions are more than just a
smudger pixels but most importantly it
reminds us to you know get our asses
back to the keyboard for the new season
this year I was really wondering how
they were going to top the call because
they really raised the bar with that I
mean it was incredible and well I'm not
going to beat around the bush here this
year's cinematic titled the brink of
infinity
it was pretty bad it was pretty bad it
was quite literally just a tech demo
tour through a pretty soulless looking
summoner's Rift we didn't see a single
Champion a single fight the only thing
that moved was this butterfly now I love
butterflies as much as an explode but
come on all we heard through this
relaxing fly through were two things a
little girl doing mashed up Champion
quotes in some sort of poem and the
sound of distant iconic League moments I
have found my limit a thousand times and
still I press further
[Music]
every mistake
a lesson the whole thing lasted for just
two minutes which means I barely had
time to process how deflate that I was
before it was all over within minutes
the comment said it all people felt let
down it was an absolute pylon of
disappointment and pretty soon twitch
chats all over the world were spamming
their streamers to try and get them to
watch this so-called cinematic but if
that is the pilot if they're gonna try
and put out that does no animation that
does nothing it's a girl talking in the
background about nobody cares about
words just to sound smart as they pan
over summoner's Rift with a camera which
by the way spectate tyler1 AKA Joe you
could do that that quality level on the
most massively played online and it's to
the point where not only people need to
be fired the game needs to be be ended
it's time to pack it up and move on
no no way this is their season 2023
cinematic
bro what was there's nothing cool about
it it was literally the map some
jokingly pointed out the invisible
Champions and abilities that people have
missed While others tried recreating the
animation for themselves using just
Microsoft Paint and a few just generally
took the piss what's up guys yeah
so we're gonna be reacting to the brand
new 2023 season cinematic for League of
Legends
pants
almost done
can't come to tipper's tea party
what's your favorite animal a bear
and there it is the 2023 League of
Legends cinematic let me know what you
guys think about it now before we go any
further on this I just want to make one
thing clear I'm sure that those that
actually worked on this that actually
put it together and not to blame her
like Natalie reminded everyone on
Twitter I don't think there's a single
Game Dev I've met that doesn't put
copious amounts of love and passion into
what they do not only for the game but
for the players too I wish more folks
understood how much work can go into a
single asset feature trailer or even
cosmetic most of the time when you get
something this lazily put together it's
because some higher up is trying to save
a bit of cash so no blame to the
designers or animators here but yeah the
fans weren't very happy aside from the
disappointment and memory people would
just generally annoyed about Riot
silence it felt like they just dropped
this thing and ran away and this poor
communication was something that Riot
admitted to themselves when they finally
addressed everyone's reaction to the
Cinematic they said we've launched a
cinematic as part of season start every
year since 20 18 and make no mistake
everyone on League knows how much you
love them this year there was some
unprecedented circumstances that had us
choose an ultimate approach to the
season 2023 video however we believed it
could still embody League's broad
universe and competitive Spirit while
celebrating the start of a new season
but we've heard your feedback and we
want to acknowledge brink of infinity Mr
Mark for the action-packed champion-led
trailer you expected and has led to
further speculation about our investment
in League honestly we should have been
more communicative which might have
helped with some of that feeling and
speculation we do believe the league has
a bright future and we are investing in
that but we can do a better job of
sharing those plans with you we are
committed to giving you more details
about what that investment looks like in
the next couple of days we really
appreciate your passion and feedback and
League success wouldn't be possible
without your dedication thank you look
sometimes people don't like cinematics
people disagree about them that's fine
but this is the first time I can
remember Riot themselves having to
address an Angry Crowd over them for
some people it's not even anger they're
feeling it's a worry that this is
emblematic of a wider theme of riots
siphoning away resources from League I
saw a few people jokingly suggesting
that this year's cinematic budget for
League must have gone straight to
valoran now under normal circumstances I
tell everyone to chill that there's no
Grand conspiracy here but did you see
what valeran got for the start of their
new season
foreign
[Music]
statement as an optimist you'll be
hoping those details about real
investment will be prompt and thorough
yesterday Riot released a beautiful
animation that was on a similar level to
most of their previous work only this
was to promote their lunar Rebel event
and the accompanying skin line as one
ready to put it I get it now the season
2023 cinematic doesn't sell any skin so
why bother the lunar skin sells a medium
amount of skin so they get a medium
amount of quality or as another simply
and quite brilliantly put it you're
kidding me now for me this all boils
down to something quite simple Riot
start of year cinematics have never just
been about generating height for people
to jump back into another year of solo
queue they were a real reminder of why
we love the game at its very core of the
Champions and moments that we've grown
attached to over the years now you might
think that's a little bit over the top
but rightly or wrongly the quality of
these animations are intrinsically
linked in people's minds to the overall
health of the game it's easy to see that
while yes a lot of people may just laugh
this off there is a deeper concern here
that this is a sign of Riot forgetting
their firstborn child a little they've
addressed it now and said that better
news is right around the corner so let's
see what they come up with
I remember seeing the Twisted Fate
cinematic way way back in the day this
was like one of their first ones they
did that actually blew my mind I
remember sending it to friends who
didn't play a league and they were just
like oh cool nice man and I was like you
don't get it it's just to faint the
master of cards I'm not even sure that's
his name